[Music]
are you excited by the thing that Elon
Musk's is don't say sex in general space
but the idea of space exploration even
though your or your species is young and
impatient ya know I do think that space
travel is crucially important long-term
even to other star systems and I think
that many people overestimate the
difficulty because they say look if you
travel 1% the speed of light to another
star system will be dead before we get
there right and I think that it's much
easier and therefore when they write
their science fiction stories they
imagine we go fast from the speed of
light because otherwise they're too
impatient right we're not gonna go
faster than the speed of light but we
could easily imagine that the human
lifespan gets extended to thousands of
years and once you do that then the
stars are much closer effectively right
and what's a hundred year trip right so
I think that that's gonna be the future
the far future not not my lifetime once
again but baby steps and unless your
lifetime gets extended well it's in a
race against time right a friend of mine
who actually thinks about these things
said you know you and I are gonna die
but I don't know about our grandchildren
that's right that's it I don't know for
predicting the future is hard but that's
at least a plausible scenario and so ya
know I think that as we discussed
earlier there are threats to the earth
known and not unknown right having
spread humanity and biology elsewhere is
a really important long-term goal
you